okay so we're we're in close when he
thrs this because if I was if I had some
distance I would have more deviation
okay so we close and I'm just going to
cover
up cover up boom and then slip and I'm
going to come to the
back my head ends up here on this back
shoulder see that we're in Clos it takes
whatever Edge I could off by moving up
the circle under under knees body lock
head behind the
shoulder
that you might have to go under with
your head you might have to flip it
over you might you have a lot of
pressure here right you might have to
maybe take a little off and then under I
don't care how you work it but principle
move up to Circle if you can move in the
eye of the storm if you can and then
you're underneath to this back
corner let's
TR you can
see we're very
close so as he throws it I move in and
up the circle
slightly not a huge amount there's no
time so for example you're just down to
normal right and I go I go to hit you
and when you're ready get it block it
block
it when you're
ready what's the why you going to block
it what's the
lesson you can't block it there's no
time okay you understand so I'm not
going to I'm not going to go here
there's no time for any of that stuff
got it so all I can do is
go that's it maybe I get a little step
and a little step
okay we're in close he goes to strike
boom I'm in here now as this pressure is
still going to keep coming he still has
his spine moving in I don't want to
compromise my posture like this cuz the
energy is still coming I'm going to get
J see you have to use
your midfoot vectoring so just like you
having all your techniques you're in
this forward C and never standing up
like modern I yoga okay so watch how he
goes I move into that posture and I'm
going to keep it and I try to keep it as
I go underneath it as much as
possible if I
feel that I'm losing it like I can't get
under that's when I flap to keep the
posture but I'm not going to go like
this you see that there was no time for
that so you're going to get hit boom and
then you pass it again faster boom pass
and then you go okay you going to hit
here and then you go okay
go boom half here two hands boom
step
out
right keep it tight to your
arm down
out using my shoulder his inner
knee
okay let's try so if you're going to do
that
uh leg lightning technique it's
here okay not on the turn boom boom leg
light then
in
okay from here we're just going to come
up and drop in the groin okay right into
that knee we'll do that knee first okay
don't hit each
other but what I'd like to
see that it's pretty
immediate that it hits him on his
rebound okay let's
try he he's it's it's a precarious thing
to get up get up one way or another okay
so uh he goes I boom I'm underneath dry
right
in boom in the groin I'm going to come
this
way okay and on this one he did not turn
over okay that's what you're looking for
he did not turn over so this foot from
here is going to Boom kick ball ball
heel ball heel and the
outou
clear
okay try it
sir okay again in my experience only
train people stay in his position that
he was in uh most people Sean me get
that please most people are going to try
to get up they go nose down always want
to look for that okay so as I go
boom in up
down I'm going to throw that over He
he'll go nose down right and he'll try
to get up and I'm looking for boom this
leg right here as he's trying to get up
from the Obscure Zone okay so
boom
boom it's not this isn't a love tap so
when you get here you throw that around
there it is there that foot F and
there's that kick right there okay
try
[Music]
for